well first I got a religious film what
was that uh all the king's horses that I
did with Grant good eve and then I went
right into The Hills Have Eyes again the
dichotomy of me so dark Hills Have Eyes
that was probably like were you was that
like at that point like the hardest
thing you've ever done it's the only
thing I'd ever done really come on it
was my first gig were you nervous
somebody asked me he said were you
worried about how dark it was were you
worried about what it would do to your
car dude it was my first like leading
role I'm going I got a card yeah
yeah okay obviously Spielberg saw that
and was like and then
um
um I did the howling and
10 with Blake Edwards was in Dudley
Moore yeah by the way Dudley Moore is
one of my favorite actors of all time oh
my God one of my favorites tell me just
tell me a story you haven't told that
you're a member of Dudley's anything
small big whatever
Dudley and I danced on Mini table tops
in Mexico
and I would uh go out with the crew and
hang out with the crew and he was just
so giving as an actor and so lovely as a
person I just I just loved him and so
there was a scene
which you'll probably remember if you
remember the movie 10. Bo Derek and
um Dudley is playing the piano oh yes
and uh so we did the scene and
Blake everybody's breaking down we're
moving on to the next thing and Dudley
starts to play and D
is sitting there so moved by his playing
that tears came to my eyes and Blake
stopped and he said everybody come back
bring everything back we're gonna get a
close-up of Dee listening to Dudley play
and it's this huge and you know that
happens to me on every set with great
directors they see something happening
on E.T in the dinner table scene
um is that the yelling thing we snapped
or no that was the Laughing thing
oh it's winning to the
big table scene where
um we are talking about maybe he just
imagined it right
and then it gets into well why don't you
call your father I can't he's in Mexico
with Sally right
when he said that as Mary
I took such a hit
and the tears I could feel the tears
coming up and I literally had the
thought as Mary
I can't let the kids see me cry so I got
up from the table and left which was not
in the script
and Stephen yells cut and he comes over
and he goes d
why did you get up and leave that's
that's not in the script and I explained
to him what happened and he looked at me
he said everybody come in you got a half
an hour I need you to build me a wall
with a running kitchen sink right there
so he could take me over to the sink and
then bring me back into that big
close-up where I says he hates Mexico
and it all just but that's a good
director they see
they see the moments and you have to you
remember that you know if you don't you
have to watch it I I haven't seen the
movie in many years and I immediately
remember that moment it almost makes me
emotional because I remember that moment
I remember like you're like like trying
yeah oh my gosh yeah and
every every every major I mean it
happened with Peter Jackson all the
Tigers yeah oh man what a what a lovely
man